a US team is on the ground tonight in
the Korean Peninsula further evidence
that the summit between President Trump
and Kim jong-un may and may in fact
happen senior foreign affairs
correspondent Greg Powell khat is in
Seoul tonight a whirlwind of activity at
the plan summit involving President
Trump and North Korean leader Kim Jong
hoon at the scene of Saturday's surprise
summit with Kim and South Korean
president moon jae-in on the North
Korean side of the DMZ US and North
Korean teams are working out the details
of the possible meeting I think the u.s.
is trying to engage North Korea's
interest in denuclearization and what
that might mean how far they're willing
to go heading up the high-powered
American side US ambassador to the
Philippines former ambassador to South
Korea and Korea nuclear negotiator song
Kim director of Korean affairs at the
National Security Council Allison Holker
who accompanied Ivanka Trump to the
South Korean Olympics in February and
assistant secretary of defense for Asia
Randal Schreiber who was with Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo on his last trip to
Pyongyang they are facing off against
powerful North Korean Vice foreign
minister Cho Sun we whose explosive
remarks last week threatening a nuclear
to nuclear showdown and calling vice
president pants a political dummy almost
blew the summit out of the water also
set to meet in Singapore the possible
venue of the summit White House deputy
chief of staff Jo Hagen and others who
with their North Korean counterparts
will plan logistics for the meeting with
more north-south inter-korean talks plan
South Korean president moon called
Monday for even more dialogue possibly a
three-way summit with the US and the
north after Singapore I think one thing
that president moon was trying to do was
to restore the communication channels
talks between US and North Korean
negotiators are set to continue here
through Tuesday and there's even talk of
one last meeting between Secretary's day
Pompeo and a North Korean official to
get the final go-ahead to the summit if
all goes well Mike Greg Powell cut in
Seoul Craig thanks a lot